much I'll be talking today
as Peter said
a bit of my dissertation research which
looks at the introduction of copyright
in the 18th century and copyrights
influence on the book market writ large
and today I'll be looking at practice
and derivative artistic practices so
text reuse image reuse and how those
sort of patterns were massaged by
changes in copyright law during the
period so this is computational research
in the humanities that sort of you know
builds on a lot of prior computational
research in the humanities the earliest
example of which I could find is work by
Patricia Margaret took who has this
beautiful hand-drawn distribution of the
number of printers and the number of
books published in the early modern
period so this is back in the 70s this
is in her dissertation pioneering work
for studies computational studies of the
early book market later work by folks
like John feather we're analyzing
distribution over topics within books
published in this period subsequent work
by Elaine violet starting to compute
some of the sort of basic descriptive
statistics of books published let's say
before 1800 in the early modern period
and then more recent work by folks like
Michael Suarez who again here he's
looking at distribution of book lengths
over over history but there's been very
little analysis of the ways in which
copyright law may have influenced the
book market in fact there's been very
little quantitative work done generally
in the humanities humanities papers tend
to be presented in tweed jackets and
read from a sheet of paper it was very
little computing going on so to set the
stage for what we'll discuss I'm just
going to sort of walk through the
relevant historical moments very briefly
copyrights invented in 1710 statutory
copyright anyway which is sort of
written law copyright before that it's
all royal proclamations and so after
1710 there are a number of cases that
are fought over a sort of derivative
where an author is abridging
plagiarizing adapting an earlier an
accident work and the plaintiff wins in
all of these cases the defendant is
unable to defend a derivative
publication best forward to 1741 and
there's a very prominent case Giles V
Wilcox which is fought over a
publication by Fletcher Giles that we
just saw
so John Wilcox said basically abridged
Giles is text and published it and Giles
was understandably upset he took Wilcox
to court and Wilcox defended his
publication on the basis that he had
liked highly manipulated the source text
he had transformed in a number of ways
he wasn't going to influence the
marketability of the original text etc
etc and so his derivative publication
was identified as a distinct
copyrightable work and was found not
infringing and so this precedent in 1741
opens up the opportunity for a number of
subsequent cases all of which have
derivative artistic text reuse that are
defensible that are found non-infringing
so this is a really sort of watershed
moment in history I mean this is the
creation of fair use copyright law and
said in 1741 at least four texts in the
image domain there was no fair use law
until a very sort of breakthrough 1785
case say anymore and
based on sayers and this was proven in
the case in the case and that becomes
like an artistic trick artists would
deliberately encode false information
into their into their pictorial graph so
that if they were sort of reprinted they
could identify those telltale marks kind
of clever but in any event because this
was a C chart and because Moore's math
made a number of improvements on the
plaintiffs mouth he his map was actually
found non-infringing it was found to be
a defensible work and so this creates
precedent for a number of subsequent
cases all of which revolve around
derivative image production where a
derivative image is found to be
non-infringing and so the research
question that that this part of my work
sort of addresses is you know does the
rise of fair use precedent incentivize
increase rates of derivative artistic
practice so once you get a precedent for
text reuse that says you can infringe on
other people's works and your work will
be defensible it'll be monetizable do we
see rises in sort of frequency of text
and image reuse and a number of
prominent scholars have sort of
contributed to this debate essentially
ronand easily professor of law has said
essentially yes and William Sinclair
who's one of the few who's tried to
actually grab some numbers to analyze
this question he said no he doesn't
think so but st. Clair is operating on
the order of just about a dozen cases
that he's kind of analyzing so what I
want to do is to adjust this question
sort of
at the level of collections and the data
for this comes from actually two
distinct repositories there's a great
collection of 18th century books the
degree to which that sample represents
the full they ladder the estc is a
bibliography of all texts known to have
been published in English from 1472 the
introduction of printing to 1800 so it's
an absolute sort of historical backbone
against which we can measure
representativeness of a corpus which is
very rare in more modern times we have
no idea the full print run of a given
historical sweep it's just too much but
we can see here that echo is sort of
highly correlated echo publication rates
are highly correlated with the est-ce so
this is a highly representative sample
corpus and so this is one of roughly
35,000,000 page scans in all of the echo
corpus all of which will be analyzed and
problems with this data one of which is
that you know we can measure
representativeness of the echo corpus
versus the English short title catalog
but we don't know what's missing from
the English short title catalog we don't
know the survival rates of books a lot
of books that kind of just disappeared
from history and there's actually very
little work on measuring like
probability that
a given work would have disappeared or
this measuring survival rates gathered
from over 2,200 libraries worldwide we
can look at just to see the library that
were basically on the verge of becoming
extinct a significant portion of sort of
book history is just absolutely missing
and can't be part of the study but we've
got decent decent numbers
whereas later the century kind of
hotbeds of reprinting because they
weren't subject to English copyright law
provisions so printers in Edinboro and
in Dublin can reprint sort of you know
wholesale they can sell records in
London they deliberately misidentify
title pages they lie and say that a
record was published in London because
London publications were sort of hotter
commodities and then there are kind of
intricacies within these different
geographic locations so for instance if
we look at nicer type intended to be
preserved
and presses they have old typeface and
so although in brown dublin are kind of
again these hotbeds of reprinting we
can't capture as much from them because
the signal is less strong so a lot of
problems with the actual data that's
said we'll begin by looking at patterns
in derivative text reuse and mean line
they're drawn roughly in the 80% region
so this is to say that the text reuse
algorithm needs to be sufficiently fuzzy
in order to work with these characters
we can't count on perfect sort of word
level transcription rates and so the
technique used for this part of the
study is called the min hash algorithm
which allows us to analyze text
sequences and identify these hashes
these sort of derive these
characteristics of the text such that we
can compare the characteristics of two
passages and identify what with a
certain probability you know whether or
not they match and so the basic notion
here is
we're going to we're going to
in which that sequence of values occurs
in the vector for the window so this
lets us analyze text reuse in linear
time which is much better than comparing
thirty five million page images to
thirty five million page images that's
nice to have that optimisation and so
with this sort of min hash technique we
can identify fuzzy text for use such as
the passages here we have a recipe it's
interesting to look at the kinds of
things that are plagiarized for recipe
books song books are often plagiarize
legal books often plagiarize and so
we'll get a chance to see some of the
actual OCR underlying some of this in a
second but this is the kind of fuzzy
text for use for trying to identify then
of course the vast majority of the kind
of aligned passages the identified
instances of text reuse are solely a
function of edition reprints so we have
three different editions of Robinson
Crusoe they're 120 something odd and in
fact if we look at reprints half of
publishing it was happening during the
period we're just reprints of a given
successful volume so we have to use
elaborate measures to sort of construct
this big graph and can connect each of
the Edition reprints with connected
components that allow us to identify
that this region is all Robinson Crusoe
whereas this is an actual plagiarism
group of Crusoe so if we flush all this
out we remove those just additional
reprints and we analyze the actual rates
of derivatives publication over the
period
ciaossu Wilcox which we would expect to
see had jowls be Wilcox influenced
derivative text publication so so far it
looks like the rise of fair use and the
text domain has not influenced text
reprinting practices what about images
well here's just the sort of image
corpus how many images are being printed
over time several thousand annually and
these are the different image types okay
in this sort of processing pipeline
there are a number of challenges posed
one of which is the sort of variance
within exposure rates so these are two
different images of the same Edition and
you can see on the left obviously we
have far less signal than the one on the
right there are these strange
eccentricities of the corpus as well
there are some times
pages one composite image that somehow
represents the two images it's almost
like an automatic page flipper got stuck
not sure other strange sort of pasted on
some eighteenth-century wall somewhere
so this is you know as sort of
reprinting of the image but there's very
little signal there to to capture that
with and then sort of philosophical
problem which is that just by virtue of
the fact that you know this is a large
space
and so even deciding in a number of
cases whether or not two images are
derivative can be difficult I think for
humans so when we run this image
computation and I'll say really briefly
that this is I had the most baroque
labyrinthine pipe pipeline for this this
involved using sort of vectorize image
representations from inception keypoint
based image analysis techniques like
sift and surf image hashing techniques
like a perceptual hash an average hash
combining all of those features together
and then actually just using an
old-school support vector machine
classifier given that feature that was
trained on three hundred thousand
observations image pairs that were
binary classified as as matching or not
matching I'm happy to share that
training data that was very painful to
collect with the Genki as web app you've
ever seen that you think that day that
we can and you can see that
the editions kind of interesting but we
can also identify a number of very
subtle plagiarisms where
this was a kind of regular occurrence
where an author and engraver and we can
identify these at scale on the Left this
is an image by Thomas Jeffries it's
ironic because Jeffries was the
defendant in a number of image dispute
cases where he was actually plagiarizing
others so there may be a sort of history
here where Jeffries is plagiarizing and
Burke is plagiarizing on top but if we
look at the great rates of imagery use
over the full sweep of the century we
can see
contain derivative images can contain
plagiaristic images over the sweep of
the century and there's no notice so to
return to the original question does the
rise of fair use precedent increased
derivative artistic practices it seems
William st. Clair was was right to think
not
thanks very much
[Applause]
[Music]